hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control SC dot
l2-3.13.16. oh we're getting up there in
that control family 13 right protect the
confidentiality of cui at rest
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP Hunter 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload uh guess what you have found
yourself in the right place you found
your home here with on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance hero and that's what I want
to see baby I want to see you in a cave
jumping from your chair nothing unsafe
okay nothing unsafe I know when you
figure out compliance you feel like a
superhero Don't Do dummy superhero
things
but you should feel good about it anyway
I digress let's jump into it okay so in
this control they are specifically
looking for answers on how you will be
protecting confidentiality uh one
thought that I had here is usually when
you hear confidentiality it's already a
clue that they may not be looking for an
answer related to encryption that's
right because they would just say
encryption like they do in other
controls in fact this is true with this
control they just want to verify how you
are keeping cui safe and confidential
our example answer here on this control
will demonstrate multiple ways of how to
prove confidentiality when it comes to
managing cui so let's Dive Right into
what the assessors are looking for on
this one and I'll show you a sample
answer what are we looking for just one
assessment point they're looking to
determine if the confidentiality of cui
at rest is protected pretty simple and
straightforward lots of ways to do it so
if we were to give a sample answer we'd
say hey cui at rest on mobile devices is
protected utilizing full disk encryption
and cui at rest on non-mobile devices is
protected by physical safeguards within
the cure physical premise hey makes
sense to me pretty simple and
straightforward and thankfully this is a
pretty easy control to deal with and hey
at on call we work with defense
contractors just like you to turn these
complicated controls into answers that
could be that simple all tailored to
your organization all delivered in a
done-for-you format so if you've had
this defars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into your lap
like a seagull on a sunny day we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
a limited gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance as your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you and your organization
if you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmmc
complianceecrets.com that's
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash that subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance earns
roll it out until the next compliance
tip my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to know
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance I'll see you on
the next one
foreign
[Music]
anyway